well the Finn's and especially the
people of Hammond Aquatica aren't the
only ones who are skeptical about
whether sanctions are the right way to
go to be a sober man from the German
Chambers of Industry and Commerce joins
us now he heads the division on Russia
and Eastern Europe it's good to have you
with us now firstly please do tell me
from your point of view how precarious
our trade relations with Russia right
now trade relations are slowing down but
they're slowing down already since last
year so exports of German industries
went down 16 percent from January to
June right now these are the latest
figures but that's all related more to -
- the economic slowdown in general and
not necessarily to the sanctions so
those sanctions that were the first ones
that were imposed in July they haven't
really kicked in yet we'll have to wait
and see what happens when we get the
August figures but now there's talk
about new sanctions I mean just that
what would you make of all those
sanctions in general especially as those
that were imposed so far haven't really
helped to solve that conflict well there
are a signal and they're a clear signal
to the Russian leadership of course they
don't solve the conflict because they
are not responsible for the conflict war
economy is not responsible for the
conflict but as I said it's a signal and
we do hope that it maybe starts a
process of more cooperation and more
work to cooperation it do you see any
signal for that not yet well who do you
think because these tit-for-tat
sanctions we've just seen it in the
report are already hurting some parts of
industry Germany has so far weather to
the crisis fairly well but eventually it
might hurt the German economy - who do
you think has the longer staying power
in this Russia or the EU well I'm quite
convinced that the EU has the the
longest day and that it will harm the
Russian economy as we see that economy
is running down and the ruble is going
down and
the stock exchange is going down
investment will stop growth will stop I
think this is very harmful for Russian
economy and the concept of modernization
is really put in question now if you say
that the EU has a longer staying power
what about Putin I mean what scenario do
you think could open the door
in order to reconciliate again without
loose it without putting losing face in
this that's a very difficult question
and it's not an economic question of
course well it's clear that he has to go
out while Russia has to go out from
eastern Ukraine and it also would have
to go out from Crimea this is an illegal
annexation this is quite clear but well
I don't see that in the nearest future
so we can only hope that economic
sanctions will do the trick to be as
well man thank you very much for joining
us